foreign
okay we have a few minutes before we get
started but you should be seeing my
first slide and there's a link there
alendowney.com BDA
that will take you to the lending page
for this tutorial and from there you can
get these slides so you can follow along
and also a link to the first notebook
if you want you can open that notebook
now or when we get to that part of the
tutorial I'll walk you through that
and we'll start in about five minutes
and once again my name is Ernest
uh we are just a few seconds to the
sacrifice session
conference the most most welcome we're
so glad to see you
uh our speaker is
ready on call so let me allow him to
get to tradition so fancy and for those
of you have just joining
thank you
okay it is just about time to start if
you are arriving
there is a slide you should be seeing
that has the URL allendowney.com BDA
that will take you to the web page for
this tutorial
and from there you can get the slides
and a link to the notebook that we'll be
using
and I'll start up in about one minute
just to give people time to
arrive follow the link let me know if
there are any problems
sorry
for those of you joining again right now
please kindly
um I'm new to your mics please
please
foreign
okay I think it's a good time to get
started
again there's a link here to
allendowney.com
BDA if you follow that link it will take
you to this page
and from here there's a link where you
can get to the slides that I'm
presenting so you can follow along and
if you want to go back because you
missed something it might be nice to
have the slides and then when we get to
the notebook there will be two links
here one option is to run the notebook
on collab and in that case you don't
have to install anything
or you can download the notebook and run
Jupiter on your own computer and use the
notebooks that way
we'll come back to this later on when we
get to the notebook but I've got some
introduction to do first so I'm going to
go back to the slides
and start by introducing myself I work
at Driven data we run data competitions
and also do data Consulting mostly for
organizations working on data science
for social good with a particular Focus
right now on human rights and climate
change
I was until this past May a professor at
Olin College while I was there I worked
on a series of uh textbooks including
think python think Bays which you might
be able to see behind me and think stats
I also write a blog called probably
overthinking it if you are interested in
the topics today you might want to read
more about it there
the topic of the tutorial is Bayesian
decision analysis and the idea is using
probability to make better decisions
under uncertainty
and if anybody out there has their
microphone on you might want to turn
that off
all right
so the introduction I'm going to start
with Bayes theorem we will work our way
up to Bayesian inference and then answer
the question of how do we use
the inferences that we make from data in
order to make good or maybe even optimal
decisions
I'm gonna we have 90 minutes so I'm
going to break it up into three chunks
about 25 minutes and then we'll take a
break
second 25 minutes and then a break and
then I'll leave some time at the end for
questions and answers although if you
have questions feel free to ask as you
go along I think the best way to do that
is to put a question into the chat and I
will try to check periodically let
how this goes we have a good number of
people which is great but it makes a
little bit hard to handle so we'll
experiment and see what see what works
I'm going to start with an example
problem which is called the multi-arm
Bandit problem and the idea is in a
casino there might be a row of slot
machines and each time you play one of
these machines you either win or lose
and suppose that we believe that the
different machines have different
probabilities of paying off different
probability of winning the question is
which one which machine should you play
and how often now of course if you know
which one is which you would play the
machine with the highest probability but
in general we don't know that ahead of
time
now this is kind of a toy problem this
isn't really how casinos work so this is
not practical but it is an analogy for
at least two other real world problems
one is Bayesian a b testing if you are
showing different versions of a web page
or different versions of an ad and you
want to know which one is the most
effective you are in a sense playing the
same game which is that each time you
show an ad you may or may not
successfully get a click or a sale and
you are simultaneously trying to figure
out which one is the best ad and which
one should I show to the next person who
comes to my web page
this is also analogous to a Bayesian
medical trial which is almost the same
thing you have a set of treatments you
have reason to believe that some of them
are more likely to work than others and
so each time you see a patient you are
simultaneously trying to decide which
treatment is the best and which one you
should prescribe to the next person the
next patient that you treat
so that's the motivating problem
for this tutorial you don't need a lot
of prerequisites we'll start with basic
probability we'll start with Bayes
theorem
if you know intermediate python you
should be comfortable with what we're
doing today we will use a little bit of
numpy and a little bit of pandas so if
you're familiar with those libraries
great and if not I'll show you what you
need as we go along
all right I'm going to start with Bayes
theorem this is Bayes theorem and this
shows the relationship on the left
between the probability of a given B
and on the right the probability of B
given a so this formula can tell you how
to go back and forth between those two
conditional probabilities
and this is often useful you can think
of it as a divide and conquer algorithm
for computing the probability of a given
B on the left hand side if it turns out
that the three terms on the right hand
side are easier to compute and sometimes
they are
so in general Bayes theorem is useful as
this kind of algorithm but more
specifically in the context of Bayesian
statistics what we are interested in is
the diacronic interpretation of Bayes
theorem so instead of A and B I'm going
to talk about H which is a particular
hypothesis about the world and D which
is some data that might be evidence for
or against that hypothesis and we're
going to use Bayes theorem to go from
the probability of H
which is the probability of the
hypothesis before you saw the data and
get to the probability of H given D and
that's the probability of the hypothesis
after seeing the data this is called the
diacronic interpretation of Bayes
theorem diacronic means through time so
it's telling us how over time we use
data to update our beliefs in a
particular hypothesis
in this context we can take the
different terms in Bayes theorem so this
is Bayes theorem again just written with
H and D instead of A and B
in this context each of these terms has
a name so the probability of H is the
prior that's here
that's what we believe about the
hypothesis before seeing the data
the probability of H given D is the
posterior that's what we believe after
seeing the data and the two things that
we need to figure out in order to solve
this equation
are the likelihood and the prop total
probability of the data the likelihood
is what is the probability of the data
given that the hypothesis is true or
maybe saying that differently if we
assume that the hypothesis is true what
would the probability of the data be
and then the denominator of Bayes
theorem is the probability of D which is
just the probability of the data under
any hypothesis at all
and that is at least sometimes a
difficult part to formulate and
sometimes a difficult part to compute
fortunately we don't always have to
compute it one way to think about what
we're doing here is Computing a
posterior that is proportional to the
product of the prior and the likelihood
so if we can compute a prior and we can
compute a likelihood we multiply them
together and then if we take the result
and normalize it so it adds up to one
this is the step where we normalize the
posterior probabilities sometimes we
don't have to compute the probability of
the data explicitly we kind of do it
implicitly
if that's not making sense I'm going to
show an example
all right so this is the five earned
problem which again is kind of a toy
problem but this is going to take us
toward where we want to go imagine that
you have five urns you can think of them
as just your bowls or containers of some
kind that contain blue and yellow
Marbles and they are numbered from zero
through four earn number zero has no
blue marbles all yellow
earn one is 25 blue earn two fifty
percent blue earn three 75 percent blue
and earn four is entirely blue no yellow
so if I pick and earn at random and you
you can't look inside you can't count
the marbles you only get to pick one
marble and look at that one marble it
turns out to be blue
which iron do you think it was that you
chose
well you know for sure that it's not
earned or earned zero because earn zero
doesn't have any blue arms
if it was earned four you would be
guaranteed to get a Blue Marble so that
seems like a likely candidate but it
also could have been three two or one so
we're not sure we don't know which earn
it was but we can ask a different
question which is what is the
probability that you chose each earned
and that's what we're going to compute
so I'm going to start with this table
I've got one row for each of these
hypotheses and I've got a column for the
prior probabilities the likelihoods and
then I'm going to multiply those two
things together and then I'm going to
normalize them to make them add up to
one and then that will give me the
posterior probabilities so I'm going to
start with the priors
if I assume that I chose
from the urns with equal probability
than the prior before I look at the
marble I don't have any other
information the prior is that each
earned is equally likely and therefore
the probability is one out of five
now to compute the likelihood the
question I'm asking is
what is the probability of getting a
Blue Marble from each of these urns
so from earn zero the probability of
getting a Blue Marble is zero
from earn one the probability is one out
of four from earn two it's two out of
four three out of four four out of four
so the likelihoods in this case come
directly from the statement of the
problem again if I go back these are the
percentages now I've written them in
terms of fractions but clearly the same
thing
and now if I take the prior and multiply
by the likelihood that's the numerator
of Bayes theorem so the product of these
things I've expressed it as a fraction
out of 20.
and if I add those up I've got 0 1 2 3 4
so that's 10 out of 20.
10 out of 20 it doesn't add up to one so
these probably these probabilities are
not like complete probabilities they're
not normalized
but what I can do is add them up I get
10 out of 20 and then divide through
and then the result is the posterior
probabilities and they are in fact
normalized they add up to one
and they kind of make sense
so the posterior probability of earn
zero is zero
the posterior probability of iron four
is four out of ten so for 40 that's the
most likely but earns three two and one
are also possible but less likely
all right so that's the earn problem
and here's one way of thinking about
what we're doing is that Bayes theorem
is a recipe for updating beliefs in
light of new data
now that is a good place for me to pause
for a second and see if we have
questions anything in the chat
or if you want to unmute and speak up
please feel free
okay
um I have a question actually what do we
do if we believe
okay
yes what do we do if we believe that
the um that the total probability is not
exhaustive of all of the possible
hypotheses that are possible
yes good question so I'm making the
Assumption here that my hypotheses are
exhaustive meaning that there's no other
possibility
and if that's not the case if I can't
make that assumption then I can't do
this step where I normalized the
posteriors
um and so that that makes things more
difficult in general to do this kind of
automated update I do need a set of
hypotheses that are exhaustive and also
mutually exclusive in other words only
one of them can be true
and exactly one of them has to be true
okay and they ask so here the hypothesis
here is you suppose uh each of the five
urns are equal the hypothesis you made
the H you made okay yeah so well there
are two parts of this one is is to just
Define what the hypothesis is so the
hypothesis that is labeled earned zero
is the hypothesis that the burn we chose
the marble from was earned zero
and then I think you also said we're
assuming that they are equally likely
and that's because before we saw the
marble and we just chose one of them at
random I'm going to assume that it was
equally likely that we could have chosen
any of the five
okay
so let's forge on for now and again
we'll have a chance to pause and take
questions every couple of minutes
um so we have done one Bayesian update
and what I mean by an update is that you
have a set of Prior beliefs you see new
data like a marble from an urn and then
you update your beliefs based on the new
data
the next part is to use those beliefs to
guide our decisions
so we'll get there and here again is the
multi-arm Bandit each time we play one
of these machines we get a piece of data
except instead of a yellow and a Blue
Marble we get a win or a lose and we'll
use that to update what we believe about
each machine and then we'll use those
beliefs to choose which machine for the
next round
all right so the underlying assumption
here is that each machine has some
unknown probability of winning and I'm
going to call it X so we're going to use
the outcomes to estimate X and then
we're going to use those estimates to
choose which machine to play
when we get to the notebook in just a
minute what we're going to do is use a
pandas series to represent a probability
Mass function and the mass function is a
set of possible values for x and their
corresponding probabilities so if I go
back to the earn example we can think of
this posterior
as a probability Mass function where
there are five possible values
which are the earned numbers and each of
them has a corresponding probability
which in this case it was 0 1 out of ten
two out of ten and so on
so when I do this computationally I'm
going to use a panda series to represent
the values and their probabilities
this is convenient because a panda
Series has two parts which are called
the index and the values I'm going to
use the index to represent a set of
possible values for x and the values in
the series are going to be the
probabilities
we're going to see this in just a minute
so if it's not making sense yet we'll
get there
all right let us get into the notebook
again if you go to this URL
allendowney.com
BBA that will take you to the landing
page for this workshop and I'm going to
go there
and here you are going to find two links
it says here's the notebook for the
workshop and you can run it on colab or
download it and here's the notebook with
Solutions so you have a choice
if you would like to type along what I'm
going to do is there are blank cells in
the first notebook
and I'm going to show you what to type
and you're going to be able to work on
exercises it will be more interactive
you will have more fun and I recommend
it however if that doesn't work for you
for any reason you also have the option
to run this notebook this notebook has
all of the solutions already in it so
you don't have to type anything
one other option is that you can run
both notebooks side by side and then if
you get stuck working on an exercise you
can look at the solutions so you have a
couple of choices I am going to click on
this link right here that says run it on
colab
and if things go according to plan it
should take me to a page that looks like
this
all right
if you are not familiar with Jupiter
notebooks let me give you a very short
introduction the The Notebook is a
document it is a sequence of cells so
for example right now this cell that
says Bayesian decision analysis is
selected if I press the down arrow it
will select the next cell this cell
contains python code so there are two
kinds of cells this one has text this
one has code
when you run that code there are two
ways to do it one is that you can press
this little triangle play symbol
and that will execute this cell of code
the other option is to hit shift and
then enter at the same time and that
will also run the cell now I'm going to
run this and you will see that it pops
up a message that says that this
notebook was not authored by Google
that's okay you can hit the Run anyway
button
okay now that ran however you will
notice that there's a message up here
that says cannot save changes
that's okay if you want to just run this
notebook for this tutorial and then when
you close this
browser your notebook will go away and
anything that you have typed will also
go away so if you want to keep a copy of
your notebook
you might want to press this copy to
drive button
that will make a copy of the notebook it
will put it into your Google Drive
assuming that you have one and
then you'll have a permanent copy of
this notebook so you might want to do
that I'm not going to do that right now
because I already have copies of this
notebook
and one thing I just did there's a
little arrow over here on the right hand
side
I'm going to close the headings so that
we have a little bit more room on the
screen
there for just second to give you all a
chance to get set up in the notebook if
it's running and everything is working
fine you can start by reading the next
section of the notebook which introduces
the problem that we just solved except
now we're going to solve it using
appendez series
so
actually this is a good time we are just
about ready for our first break
so let me pause here I'll give you a
chance to get the notebooks working if
there are any technical problems let us
know and we can help with things and we
will start up again in five minutes so
that is 10 28 at on my time 28 minutes
past the Allen
I'll see you in five but also if you
have questions let me know
um
okay we're back
let's see so the first example is the
earn problem
here's the setup I'm going to use this
array called hypos
to represent the hypotheses 0 through 4.
and then I'm going to create this series
that has two parts it has these values
and this index
and here is the result if I scroll down
just a little bit let me bring this up
to the center of the screen
here's what I get which is a series that
has the index 0 1 2 3 4 and it has the
values one-fifth which is represented as
0.2
and here at the bottom it says that the
data type is a floating Point number so
those are the point twos
so this pandas series represents five
hypotheses and their prior probabilities
just as we saw in the table the prior
probabilities are all equal to one-fifth
all right the next step
and I have run that cell now one thing
to keep track of with Jupiter notebooks
try to run all the cells in order if you
skip a cell you might have a missing
variable and if you run the cells out of
order you might get some strange errors
so I have run this one
I'm now going to run this one that says
that the likelihood
of each earn
is the the number of its hypothesis
divided by four let's see what that
result looks like
so the numbers 0 1 2 3 4 when I divide
them by four I get zero point two five
point five point seven five and one and
what that's telling me is
the likelihood of the data the
likelihood of a Blue Marble
if it was earned zero is zero because
earn zero has no blue marbles if it was
earned one the probability is 0.25 if it
was earned two it's point five earn
three point seven five and if it was
earned four then I know for sure that
I'm going to get a Blue Marble and
therefore the probability is one or a
hundred percent
so I ran that cell let me scroll down
and now here is the fundamental step in
all evasion updates which is to take the
prior probabilities and multiply by the
likelihoods let me run this cell
and we can see that the
unnormalized posterior probabilities
so this is the numerator of Bayes
theorem is zero
0.05
0.1 0.15 and 0.2
and if I add those things up
the total is 0.5
so all of these results so far this is
the same as what we got with the table
the difference is that we're using this
pandas series to do the computation
and then the last step is to take my
unnormalized posteriors divide through
by the probability of the data and the
result should be posterior probabilities
that do in fact add up to one
and these values the
0.1.2.3 and 0.4 again should be the same
as what we got when we did it using a
table
so how is this going so far any question
either about running the code in the
notebook or about this way of using a
pandas series to represent a set of
either prior or posterior probabilities
hmm
okay I see one question about where we
are in the slides where I got to is here
which introduces The Notebook
so just to recap Where We Are
we I stated the multi-arm Bandit problem
and then
introduced
The Notebook
and where we just finished doing the
earn problem in the notebook and now
we're going to do the multi-arm Bandit
problem in The Notebook
yeah
oh what color is this good
all right
so what we're going to do with the
multi-arm Bandit is very similar to what
we just did with the urns except that
there are going to be more hypotheses
instead of five urns there are going to
be kind of like 101 earns and I'll
explain what I mean by that in just a
second
so
let's say that I I just walk into a
casino and I have no idea what the
probability of winning is now in reality
it's probably low because we know it's a
casino we have background information
but let's pretend we don't
possible that I never win it's the
probability of winning is zero it's
possible that it's a hundred I'm gonna
make
101 hypotheses to represent the values
between zero and a hundred to represent
the probability of winning or rather the
percentage of winning so I'm going to
create x's and those are going to be the
range of values
from 0 to 101 and I'm going to go ahead
and print those
so I'm using uh np.a range and that is
the numpy function that makes a range of
numbers and in this case it's from 0 to
100.
and I'm assigning that to X these are
going to be the hypotheses so zero
represents the hypothesis that my
probability of winning is zero and a
hundred means the hypothesis that my
probability of winning is a hundred
percent
the probability the prior probability
associated with each one of these
hypotheses is one over the length of the
X's
which should be
a little bit less than 0.1 it's 1 over
101.
and now I can make append those series
I'm going to make a p d dot
series
that has the probabilities
and the hypotheses
I'm going to specifically say index
equals X's to make it explicit that
that's the index
and the result
is
this Panda's series
that has in the left column
the hypothetical values of x from 0 to
100 and the right hand column is the
prior probabilities which are all equal
and I'm going to assign this
to a variable called prior
and if you like you can display the
first few values from a series
like that
or
you can use the next cell
once you have
this code working
you can run the next two cells and
they'll show a graphical representation
of the prior but before I do that I want
to leave this up on the screen for just
a second and give you a chance to finish
typing
all right so I created a panda series
that represents a probability Mass
function and in particular it is the
prior probability for each value of x
from 0 to 100 and if you now run prior
Dot Plot
we can see what that prior probability
looks like it is a uniform distribution
all of the values from 0 to 100 are
equally likely and if you want
you can label the axes which is always a
good idea so we'll have uh let's see
decorate
X
what do I call this decorate and I'm
going to give it a title this is my ryer
technically this is a prior distribution
so what's on the x-axis are all the
possible values of x from 0 to 100 those
are the probabilities of winning and on
the y-axis are the likelihood of each
possible value
the prior probability of each possible
value to be technically correct
all right
now we are ready to do an update
in order to do that we have to figure
out the likelihood of the data under
each hypothesis
so let's say that I pick a machine I
play the machine and I win so the data
is a successful outcome a victory I
would like to compute what is the
likelihood
of winning
for each possible value of x now
remember that the X's go from zero to a
hundred
if I divide by a hundred
what that means is that when X is zero
the probability of winning is zero
when X is a hundred the probability of
winning is 100 divided by 100 which is
one probability equals one is certainty
so in general if I divide by divide X by
a hundred that's the likelihood of
winning
and now I can do a Bayesian update which
is I can take the prior and multiply by
the likelihood of a win
take the prior and multiply by the
likelihood of the win
the result of that is the unnormalized
posterior probabilities I'm going to
assign that to posterior stereor
like that
and then as we did with the earn problem
I can compute the posterior dot sum
that's the denominator of Bayes theorem
that's the total probability of the data
and if I divide through if I take the
posterior and divide by
the total probability of the data the
result will be a normalized posterior
distribution
which I can plot
and we'll see what that looks like
I'm going to go back in just a second
and show that code but to look at the
result what this is saying is
after we play the machine and we see
that we won once
what that means is that the high value
High values of X are more likely and the
low values of X are less likely and in
fact it turns out to be a linear
relationship
so let me back up
just to make sure that we all have the
code we need
so here's the Bayesian update I compute
the likelihood
I multiply the prior by the likelihood
and then divide through by the total
probability of the data and the result
is the posterior distribution that tells
me what I believe about X having seen
one piece of data which is that I played
the machine once and I won
let me pause there give you a chance to
catch up and also ask questions if you
have them
okay
so good so far again the imaginary
scenario here is that we pick the
machine we played once and we won and
now this is what we believe about X
which is the probability of winning
suppose we play the same machine again
and win again
we can do a second update we're going to
use the posterior from the first update
as the prior for the second
and here's what that looks like
here's that code I'm going to take the
posterior from the first update I'm
going to multiply it by the same
likelihood again because we won again
and that gives me posterior 2. divide
through by the total and then plot the
result
so here's what the posterior looks like
after I have played twice and won twice
so what this is saying is that if I keep
playing this this machine and I keep
winning
I become more and more confident that X
is probably close to 100 percent and
it's unlikely to be as low as 20 percent
and it's definitely not zero
and you can see that there's some
curvature here you might guess that
that's a parabola and you would be right
because I've taken this line and
multiplied it by itself
so I'm getting
in polynomials with increasing order if
you want to think about it
mathematically
all right let's do one more update
which is suppose we play the same
machine again but this time we lose
so we're going to do a very similar
update except now I need
the likelihood
the likelihood of a loss
and in the same way that I argued that
if you tell me what x is then I know the
probability of winning well it's also
true if you tell me what x is I know the
probability of losing it's 1 minus the
likelihood of a win
so the likelihood of a loss is the
complement of the likelihood of a win
and now I can do
a very similar update
except that this time instead of
likelihood win I'm using likelihood loss
I'm taking posterior 2 and that was my
posterior distribution after seeing the
first two data points the first two wins
multiply by the likelihood of a loss and
same update divide through by the total
and then plot the result
and this if you guess that that is a
cubic curve you would be correct
and what it is saying is that the
probability that X is a hundred percent
is now zero because I've seen a loss I
know for sure that it can't be zero I've
also seen a win so I know it can't be
I think I said the wrong thing there I
know it can't be zero and I know it
can't be a hundred percent
it looks like at this point the most
likely value of x is somewhere between
60 and 80
and in fact it turns out to be at
66.666 percent which is two-thirds which
is the proportion of winds in my data
set
so if you win two times out of three the
most likely value of x is two-thirds
but this distribution is telling us
we are still very uncertain about what x
is it could possibly be 80 it might even
be 90. could be 50 or 40 but less likely
to be 30 less likely to be 20 and very
unlikely to be down near zero
so at any point in time after any amount
of data this distribution is telling us
what values of x
are most likely
relative to each other
all right
what I've done here is I've taken that
update that we just did and put it into
a function
so this function takes a pmf a
probability Mass function and this is
going to represent the prior when I get
this thing it's going to represent the
prior
this function also takes data and data
is a string that is either a w or an L
meaning a win or a loss if it's a win
then the likelihood the relevant
likelihood is the likelihood of a win
if it's a loss the relevant likelihood
is the likelihood of a loss and now
this update
is very similar to what we've seen
except that I'm doing the multiplication
in place so rather than saying prior
times likelihood I'm taking my prior and
I'm doing a times equals the likelihood
and then dividing through by the sum
so this update function takes the prior
probability
takes the prior distribution multiplies
by the likelihood divides through by the
sum and then the results the result is
that I have modified that existing
series
so let me show an example
I'm going to start by making a copy of
the prior distribution
and I'm doing that because this function
modifies the pmf the series that we pass
as an argument so before I modify the
prior I'm going to make a copy of it
and then I can run my update function
I'm going to pass this pmf
as an argument and I'm going to pass in
as the data
the W string
so if I run that
seems to have worked and now if I plot
the results I can do a PM f
Dot Plot
and a decorate and let's put a title on
it that says this is the posterior
distribution
this now is the same thing that we saw
before
when we did One update with one win
and
I can
repeat that
so I'll do three updates two wins and
one loss and then plot the result
which should look like what we had
before
so there is that
and again what I'm doing here I'm making
a copy of the prior updating it with two
wins and one loss and then plotting the
result so let me just update my title so
this is two wins one loss
and now there's an exercise
so suppose you play a machine 10 times
and only win once
what is the posterior distribution of x
in other words what should we believe
about X if we play the machine 10 times
and we only win once
now for your convenience I have created
a string that contains one W and nine
L's so you can use a for Loop to iterate
through that string and do an update
that is very similar to this
so I'm going to start
with a copy of this
and let's do the exercise
so take a minute work on that let me
know if you have any questions and I
will show a solution in just a few
minutes
yes I see a couple of questions in the
chat let me show likelihood loss
is something that you need to Define and
here is where it's defined
the likelihood of the data
if you see a loss is one minus the
likelihood even that it's a win
and someone else asked are these
likelihoods changing the answer is no
the likelihoods are the same
so the the likelihood of the data given
a win and the likelihood of the data
given a loss those are in a sense those
are constants
however as I see wins and losses I am
multiplying them together in different
combinations
I hope that makes sense
ah there's a question here that says how
bad is it to use some of your data to
form a prior should you never Peak and
if you do should you ignore that and use
a uniform prior
that is a complicated question let me
give a short answer now which is in
general you should not use the data to
form a prior and then use the data to do
an update because if you do that you are
in some sense double counting the data
you are pretending that you have more
data than you do and so the result will
be more certain than it should be
so that's the most basic answer there
are exceptions to that there are cases
where it is okay to peek at the data but
the general rule is that you only get to
use the data once
all right
now
let's do this exercise
so for data in outcomes
I'm just going to do one update with
each let me call it outcome just to be a
little bit more clear so each time I
play a machine I get an outcome and each
time I get an outcome I'm going to do an
update and then I'm going to plot the
posterior with one win and nine
nine losses now before I run this let's
think about what we expect it to look
like
if I only win one time out of ten then
the most likely value of x is one tenth
and values that are more than about 20
or 30 are seeming unlikely at this point
so let's see what that looks like as a
distribution
there it is
all right
so I copied the prior distribution I
updated it with each of the outcomes one
win nine losses and here's what the
result looks like the peak the most
likely value is in fact very close to
one-tenth which is the observed
proportion of winds everything from
about 40 percent on up is quite unlikely
at this point and notice that the width
of this distribution is getting narrower
and what that means is that I'm becoming
more and more certain about what x is
when I only had three pieces of data
this distribution was really wide it
goes from about 20 up to 90.
now it looks like it's kind of in the
range from maybe some low single digits
up to about 40.
all right so as I get more and more data
this posterior distribution is telling
me that I am more and more certain about
what the value of x is
all right it is time for our second
break when we come back we will now
extend this instead of having just one
machine we will have four machines if
you want during the break you can read
ahead a little bit to see where we're
headed
and we will resume at the top of the
hour
okay we'll start up again in about 10
seconds
all right let's get back to work
the next section of the notebooks takes
us from one machine to four machines and
I'm going to assume that
these are the actual probabilities of
women so machine number zero has a zero
percent chance of winning machine number
one has a ten percent chance Machine 2
is 20 machine 3 is 30. however
we have to pretend that we don't know
this because obviously if we knew the
probabilities of winning we would just
take the best machine and that's the
machine that we should play all the time
so the premise is that we don't know
which machine is which we don't know
what these probabilities are and we're
going to figure them out by playing the
machines
so I'm going to simulate
what it
playing these machines I'm going to run
a simulation I'm going to use this flip
function to
choose a random value and then return
true with the given probability P so if
the probability of winning is 10 this
will return true 10 of the time
and I've got this function called play
that is going to take as a parameter
the which machine I want to play
and it will look up the actual
probability of winning
flip a coin with that probability and
then return either W or L with the given
probability so I'm going to Define flip
I need to run this cell I'm going to
Define play and run this cell
and now if I take machine 3 and play it
10 10 times and print the results what I
see in this case is I got nine losses
and one win
now I was expecting about three out of
ten so this was a little bit unlucky but
if I run it again
I get two wins if I run it again
I got four wins so in the long run the
average is about three
or thirty percent
okay now I want to make four copies of
the prior distribution in order to keep
track of what I believe about each of
the four machines so I'm going to create
a list called beliefs I'm going to use a
list comprehension to make a prior dot
copy
for I in range 4. so I'm making four
copies of the prior distribution and
assigning the list
to beliefs
and I've got a function here that is
going to plot all four of those
distributions now before I run this
function I want to give you a chance to
get this code going
and then we'll see what the result looks
like
prior dot copy for I inrange4
put it in a list comprehension
and if you plot the results
it looks like this
so I've got one posterior distribution
what I currently have is the prior
distribution I have one prior
distribution for each of the four
machines machine zero one two three and
for each one I currently don't know
anything so it's a uniform distribution
okay
so as an example I'm going to play each
machine 10 times and then plot those
distributions so for I in range
four
so that's going to Loop through the
different machines and then for I don't
need a variable in range
10.
I'm going to
play machine I
and then update
my beliefs about machine I
beliefs bracket I
based on that outcome
boom there we go
okay so when I run this Loop
it's going to Loop through the four
machines so I is going to go machine
zero machine one machine two machine
three
it's going to run this Loop 10 times for
each machine
which time through it's going to play
machine number I
and record the outcome
and then do an update and it's going to
update beliefs bracket I
with that outcome
so this is as if I walked into into the
casino and just played each machine 10
times and here's what my posterior
distributions look like
so machine zero
it looks like has a very low value of x
possibly zero
machine one in this case looks even
worse
machine two looks pretty good and
machine three looks pretty good
now because I played each machine only
10 times these outcomes won't
necessarily represent exactly what the
actual probabilities are but they are a
reasonable approximation of those
probabilities
so we're going to go back to the slides
in just a second but let me pause here
and see if there are questions
so again what I've done I made four
copies of the prior
and then
I plotted the priors
I played each machine 10 times and then
I plotted the posterior distributions
and there's what that looks like and let
me get the code up there as well
to give you a chance to catch up
let me take a quick look in the chat see
if we have questions
ah I got a comment from someone that
their distributions are different yes
that is likely remember that we are
flipping coins here so the outcomes are
random and so yours will probably look
different
although it is likely it's not certain
but it is likely that machines zero and
one will come out looking relatively bad
meaning the distribution is off to the
left and machines two and three should
look better with the distributions off
to the right
but it is it's always possible that they
will just because of random chance end
up looking different
and in fact I see that there are about a
hundred people we have 124 people in the
workshop so
um you're gonna get different outcomes
ah what's a good number of Trials to
start making decisions
all right that is a great question it's
exactly where we're headed next so I'm
going to jump back to the slides because
this is the question that I want to
answer
in a sense what we just did is a
preliminary trial we collected some data
we updated our beliefs and now we have a
posterior distribution for each machine
now what
there are a couple of options so one
option is to say okay I'm gonna figure
out which machine looks the best maybe
I'll compute the mean value from that
posterior distribution I'll figure out
the mean and that's the machine I'm
going to play from now on
okay that could work but there's a
problem which is that because of random
chance it's possible that machine 2 or
even machine one had the highest result
after my preliminary trial and if that's
the case then I would end up playing the
wrong machine or at least the not best
machine over and over forever so that's
bad
option number two is I could keep
playing all the machines
with equal probability
for a very large number of Trials until
I'm very sure that I know which one was
the best now the problem with doing that
is that these are let's suppose real
patients that we are treating and we are
giving them a prescription that might
not be the best prescription
I don't want to run a trial for ten
thousand people if it means that I'm
giving a bad treatment to such a large
number of people
so what I ideally want to do is choose
each machine in proportion to the
probability that it's the best and this
strategy is called Thompson sampling and
the idea is that we are going to choose
a random value from each posterior
distribution and then whichever machine
yields the highest value that's the
machine that I'm going to play next or
if you think about it as a medical
treatment it means sort of each time a
new patient comes in I'm going to choose
a random treatment but not with equal
probability if I think that a treatment
is is the best I'm going to choose it
more often but as long as I'm not sure I
will keep using each of the treatments
sometimes
so let's see what that looks like let's
jump back to the notebook
all right
so what I need in order to implement
this strategy is I need a way to choose
a random value from a posterior
distribution and then I'm going to
compare them to each other so this
function is called pmf choice and it
uses
numpy.random.choice to choose one of the
values from the pmf except not with
equal probability it's going to use
pmf.values those are the probabilities
so that if one of them is more likely
than the other it is more likely to be
chosen
so this chooses a random value from a
posterior distribution
and I can show an example
if I
take beliefs bracket zero that's what I
believe about
machine zero and run it in this case I
got the value one in general I'm going
to get values that are
between zero and a hundred
but because machine is not very good
machine zero is not very good most of
the values that I get are relatively low
like 38 is probably about as high as I'm
going to get almost everything else is
going to be lower
If instead I chose for machine three I
would start to see some higher values
like 54. 28 and so on
okay
so that is a way to choose from a
posterior distribution now I'm going to
choose one value from each of the four
posterior distributions and pick the
largest one what I'm actually going to
return is the ARG Max what ARG Max does
is it gives me the index of the machine
that generated the highest random value
from its posterior distribution
and if I run this
if I run it once I got Machine 2
and what you should see is that machines
two and three come up more often and
machines one and zero and one come up
less often in fact so far I've had all
twos and threes and no zeros and ones
if I oh there's a two no okay
so choose has the property that the
probability of choosing each machine is
equal to its probability of superiority
which is the probability that it is in
fact the best treatment
and so now we're going to put all this
together and implement this strategy so
this function is called choose play
update and it represents what I'm going
to do by picking a machine playing the
machine once and then updating my
beliefs based on that outcome
so we're going to fill in the missing
pieces of dysfunction
and if you want you can make a copy you
can fill it in in place or make a copy
I'm going to make a copy just so I can
show both
fill this in
all right
so to choose a machine I'm going to run
the choose function
and that's going to be based on my
current set of beliefs so given what I
currently know about the machine I'm
going to choose one
and then that's the machine that I'm
going to play so I'm going to play the
machine that I chose
and record the outcome and then I have
to update my beliefs based on the
outcome so beliefs bracket machine
based on the outcome
so those are the pieces and the reason I
think it's useful to look at it in a
function like this
is that we can see how the information
flows through this process
I use my current beliefs
to choose which machine to play
depending on which machine I play that
determines the outcome and then based on
the outcome I'm updating my belief about
that machine that I played
so that's this function I'll give you a
second to type in those changes and then
we'll run it
Define this function
and then if I run it the output with
this verbose flag it tells me which
machine was chosen and what the outcome
was
so I can run it a few times the first
time I chose machine three and I won
and then I chose machine three and I
lost
and then I chose machine two and I lost
and so on
so
let's try it out and let's start out
fresh assuming that we don't know
anything about any of the machines so
I'm going to make
another copy of the priors so again I'm
going to have all uniform priors and I'm
also going to reset this counter the
counter keeps track of how many times I
play each machine
and I'm going to play it a hundred times
and then see what the results look like
so let me just get that code back up
there again I'm making four copies of
the prior resetting the counter and now
I've set num plays equal to 100 I'm
going to Loop through 100 times and run
that function that we just filled in
and at the end
here's what I've got
machine zero is still way off to the
left I think machine zero is bad I think
machine one is bad two looks pretty good
and three looks the best
so in fact after a hundred trials
I have correctly identified the machine
that is the best
and that's good
but the other thing to look at
is the counter
and this counter is telling me how many
times I played each machine
now again your results are going to be
different because all of this is random
but what this is saying is that the
first hundred times that I played this
game
I only used
machine zero eight times
and machine one nine times in other
words I avoided the bad machines
most of the time
I used Machine 2 27 times and the
Machine that is actually the best
is the one that I played 56 times and
remember that when I started I didn't
know which machine was the best
and that's what this strategy does is it
lets me simultaneously figure out which
machine is the best while at every point
along the way taking advantage of the
knowledge that I have so far
I'm going to go back and run it one more
time
I have to say that one was an unusually
good outcome but it's not atypical let's
see how we do
here's another example ah actually this
one's even better
so despite the fact that when I started
playing this game I did not know which
machine was the best
after a hundred trials I used the best
machine 61 times and the second machine
23 times
so that's a pretty good outcome
that's the end of The Notebook so let me
pause for a second and see if you have
questions and then I'll go back to the
slides to review a couple of things and
then we are almost done
all right let me do a little wrap up
we are back from The Notebook
yes I see a question that could I use uh
the counter to generate something like a
confidence interval yes in fact I think
I didn't do it in this notebook
but I can from these posterior
distributions I can make a confidence
interval what I can do is I can find a
lower bound and an upper bound where the
total probability in between is let's
say 90 or 95 percent
is it possible to get a multimodal
distribution
not from this kind of update no but even
if it were a multimodal distribution
Thompson sampling would still work it's
just that when I choose a random value
from the posterior it would come from
one mode or the other but the the idea
would still work
okay so here's how this works initially
all the prior probabilities are equal
and so when we start out we're playing
all the machines equally but as we as we
learn more we start to see that one of
the machines looks better and so we
start playing that machine more often so
there's a positive feedback loop the
better machine gets played more often
and therefore we become more convinced
that it's the best machine until
eventually we're playing the best
machine all the time at least with very
high probability
all right this is the shortest example I
can think of in 90 minutes we've gone
from very little background knowledge to
an example that demonstrates what I
think is what Bayesian methods are good
for which is that we can use data to
update our beliefs and then use those
beliefs to guide our decisions
now there are two more examples that I'm
going to just outline for you very
quickly we are almost out of time so I
won't get into details but I'll tell you
both of these examples come from books
of mine including think Bay so I'm going
to point you to these examples one of
them is a game show called The Price is
Right Where the goal is to optimally bid
on a set of prizes and the red line
example is one where we're making a
decision about whether to stay or go and
wait for public transportation so I'm
not going to spend time on these now I'm
just going to take a couple of minutes
to point you to some additional
resources and then we'll do some q a
so you can take a look at these slides
sometime if you like
or you can read the book
all right
I did want to make a comment about
Bayesian and frequentist statistics
if all you care about is estimating a
single quantity
and having a point estimate is good
enough for your application then
frequentist and Bayesian statistics are
fine you can use whichever one you want
the advantage of Bayesian methods is
that they guide decision making under
uncertainty in a way that frequentist
methods don't and this example
demonstrates that because we have the
entire posterior distribution and we use
the entire posterior distribution not
just a point estimate in order to use
Thompson sampling in order to make good
decisions
so if you remember one thing from today
this is it Bayesian methods guide
decision making under uncertainty
as promised I want to point you to some
resources one of them I have an uh a
dice game that I call the shakes and it
is it uses dice to implement Thompson
sampling so you can do what we just did
except it you do it as a game where you
roll dice and move tokens and and all
that so if you would like to teach
Thompson sampling to someone else this
is a fun way to do it
I mentioned think Bayes the examples
that I've talked about are all from
think bays and there is a free version
of this book online if you just Google
for the title you will find it so I
recommend that as a resource more
generally if you are interested in
exploratory data analysis I have a
related book called think stats again
there's a free version of that
online
I'll also recommend this book which is
called information Theory imprints and
learning algorithms this is the book
where I first learned about Bayesian
methods so there is a uh a spot for it
in my heart and I recommend it to you it
is also available free online
and last I want to recommend statistical
rethinking by Richard mcelreuth this is
uh I think a really nice explanation of
the idea of statistical modeling so I
recommend that book that one I think is
not available free and then last if you
are interested in the history of
Bayesian statistics this is a book
called the theory that would not die
that I recommend this is a general
history not like technical details
like to get in touch with me here are
the five ways to find me
in addition to Twitter I am now also on
Mastodon if you want to find me there
so let me stop and see if you have
questions again you can either put them
into the chat or
speak up whichever you're more
comfortable doing and tell me what I can
help with
let's see is there a parameter to
control the stubbornness of the Bayesian
banded algorithm
that is to influence the amount of
attempts on the least winning machine
from the example
yes yes so
you can choose a prior and the prior
will cause you to either
um be more confident or less confident
in the outcome
so if you let's say you're doing a
medical trial and you have
uh background information that says look
I you know I think this treatment is
very likely to be effective then you
might have a prior that gives more
weight to values that are up near 60 70
80 percent and less value
um less probability at the bottom end so
yes by choosing the prior you can make
Thompson sampling be a little bit more
aggressive or a little bit more stubborn
as you said
what priors is that for such an example
uh five balls in an urn draw them with a
replacement
yeah so in the earn problem we don't
really have any background information
because it's kind of a fake problem but
in reality we almost always have some
expectation so thinking about a medical
trial again if you think about like the
cobit vaccines
um you know by the time they had done
the first round of testing they had a
lot of evidence that they were effective
so they could have put a highly
informative prior in that example
other examples we really don't have any
background information
good
thank you all for the nice comments I
see some nice thank yous I I hope this
was useful for you
uh any other questions
any complex uses of these
thank you
um yeah let me point you to think Bays
again there's an online version of the
book I have some additional examples
online now that didn't make it into the
book
um and then
one of the chapters there is about using
pi MC which is doing Markov chain Monte
Carlo sampling
and that's uh that's a good step towards
some more advanced applications
ah okay someone has given us a link
let's see what that is
ah okay yep yeah so I'm using python but
all of this stuff is available in r as
well so if you're an R person looks like
that could be a good resource for you
great
is Thompson sampling optimal in any
sense
um yes and I actually I forget I forget
actually what the definition of optimal
is but yes there's a there's a way in
which it's optimal I forget the details
um the resource for Markov chains I
mentioned my book which is think Bays
one of the chapters there is about using
pi MC
um
so you could start there but there's
also there's a ton of other good stuff
out there but but for python Pi MC is
the primary package that people use so
that would be a good place to start
I see a question that asks whether think
Bays is a just frequentist or also Bayes
it is kind of neither it is mostly
exploratory data analysis there's just a
little bit of statistical imprints in
there which is kind of frequentist but
most of it is is just describing data
okay
I think oh go ahead please
oh thank you so much and then the talk
was so awesome I really enjoyed and I'll
be contacted you very very soon
keep in touch and attend this thank you
so much for making it for the session
um which we have to push up a brother
recording and it shall be sending it to
you soon
we will communicate you on how you
receive the recording so you can
continue to bring it up
and uh if you have another question or
there is nothing else you can really add
on I would say thank you so much on my
side it's good night so I don't know on
your side it's kind of dark so
say have a great evening have a good
morning it's morning and nice good night
thank you so much for this session
see you later on in the conference we're
still moving on so you can still go
ahead and sign up for our sessions
goodbye
very good thank you and thank you for
moderating and to everybody who's still
here I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference bye-bye bye bye